the economic crisis in lebanon is never
ending
and now it is ravaging the hospitals
four-year-old radiana is fighting
leukemia
but she still finds the energy to wipe a
tear from her father's eyes
making sure she has enough medication
has left him at breaking points
[Music]
in the next bed at the rafiq hariri
hospital another family is facing the
same struggle
helen has ovarian cancer and worries
there won't be the drugs to finish the
treatment
sometimes the doctor said
inshallah helen you will get it
we don't know you have to go and see
yani i have to go a robert
by myself to see if they will give us
the medicine or not yet
this time it was okay thanks god
this country used to rank highly for
medical care but standards have
plummeted along with a currency which
has lost 90 percent of its value
putting essentials out of reach
you can see here in the pharmacy just
how short they are of drugs
but the crisis in the health care system
is really a symptom of a wider crisis in
lebanon or a series of crises
compounded by bad governance and
corruption
now this is where the cancer drugs are
kept
and you can see
it's the same picture
more cupboards with empty shelves
for doctors on the front line it is like
walking through an abyss every day
and the problems are getting worse
drugs and drugs unavailable it was
around 70 percent concerning the patient
i think it will be around
30 to 40 percent 30 to 40 percent of
patients cancer patients in lebanon are
going untreated
in our department
in our department
move outside and there is no escaping
this crisis
on the way across town to a private
hospital to see if the situation is any
better we pass the endless fuel cues
it's estimated 78
of the population is now living in
poverty
leaving some scavenging for whatever
they can find
but it doesn't matter where you are from
for everyone life is difficult
and arriving at st george hospital there
are no exceptions
retired pharmacist dikran kurelian has a
type of blood cancer the drugs he was on
have run out and he's now starting a
different treatment
his wife mary is also sick she has
ovarian cancer
we are fighting for everything even for
a little bit of breath you know
even if we want to eat
even if we want to go somewhere we don't
have gasoline
it's a very very bad situation
what is happening here has left many
people questioning their future already
many medics have emigrated
acute staff shortages add to the list of
problems
in this economic crisis the worst for
more than a hundred years
even the hospitals have now become
casualties
alex rossi sky news
beirut
you